[Applause]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of flager 2 i'm andrew schultz i
got akash singh here alex media mark
gagnon
taylor taylor gang on her period came in
woofing
yep yelling at us all saying yo i'm on
my period
and while we talking about discharge
trump just got discharged
from the hospital what's going on though
is going home now did trump beat corona
is corona
over do we not have anything to worry
about anymore chris christie got it
if chris christie survives i don't
believe in corona though
chris christie chris christie yeah dude
it's the penguin
he's danny devito bro yo real talk real
quick if this guy survives
corona doesn't exist he's like magic
johnson to aids
yeah he's like like break that down
what is it i don't know really where i'm
going to go with this
okay but you guys are going outside oh
yeah
can i try you guys are on board so i'm
just going to leave it there magic beat
aids
okay and now you start looking at areas
like is that your real magic got it in
thank you i don't look at aids like that
why not i'm still terrified i be [ __ ]
gay dudes all the time
that don't know you're actually straight
bro
our guys coming out in the beginning of
the episode before they know our humor
what you gonna do hey guys you know
those dudes
we're gonna go off this hypothetical why
would i do such a thing like that
yeah you're right we progressive over
here yeah if chris christie can get it
and bounce back
it's like oh i mean he's gonna bounce i
don't know if it's gonna be back he
might be into a grave but that guy's
built for bouncing
i'm just i just can't believe that this
guy got it
chris christie trump
a bunch of people kellyanne conway i
think she
she's good right she's skinny she's a
little old but she's skinny
she's a little tim burton character yeah
oh she looks like i remember before
christmas she is a nightmare for
christmas halloween all them [ __ ]
but i think she could make it kaylee
mcinanny oh no it's kaylee mcinnaty i
was thinking that mitch
she's the new kellyanne conway okay
she's younger kelly hancock you know
trump gets younger brother oh yeah
someone's gonna go with these old ones
yo
trump is like a gm he's just trying to
get younger at the position
real talk that's literally what kelly
mcany whatever her name is
how irish bruh just relaxed
holy [ __ ] she'd be coming up to the
podium like all right what are the
questions
so um i'll break this whole thing down
with us to us man
what trump what's going on so trump is
so
both candidates agree to get tested
before the debate
what this is the debate tuesday tuesday
so tuesday both candidates agree to get
tested before the
yeah they were supposed to get there but
i believe five to six hours earlier
before the debate that's right because
it's live
okay so trump gets there late and he's
like hey guys i don't want to hold up
anything
honor system i'm good let's just go on
so we can start on time
and they still started a little bit late
yeah yeah
and biden does get tested body gets sexy
he's negative
he's negative yeah trump shows up late
so he's like yo let's just get it
popping yep
because it's a 15 minute what'd you say
mark rapid response test there's a 15
minute rapid response test
so potentially
they know that trump has it or could
have it and they know that because hope
hicks
fell ill what day monday was it i think
she has confirmed
one or it was confirmed wednesday i
think
okay but hope hicks but i think there
was an aide said that she was sick
on monday on monday right i think she's
self-quarantined in the plane if you
guys don't know who hope hicks is
hope hicks was like an aide of trump's
it was a french
a peace and a friend
of ivanka ivanka that's some og [ __ ]
when you start smashing your daughter's
friends bruh
yo this girl's come up was so wild i
talked to him i hopped on her wikipedia
as a fight of course you did
so basically she is so like i saw a
picture on facebook first yeah it was
like hope hicks gives trump corona and i
was like all right we gotta find out
what the deal with her is because she's
like amazing in the picture
yeah i'll get a picture up so we can
show to people so basically the deal
with who picks is like she used to be a
model she's like some connecticut girl
rich she was like tight with ivanka was
like managing all her [ __ ]
and then in 2014 trump goes yo i think
or no 2015 she goes i'm gonna run for
president
maybe it was late 2014. and literally
sits her down
she has no political experience he goes
you're gonna be my press secretary
and she goes all right she's like 26
or 28 or something nah that young she's
young she's friends with ivanka isn't
ivanka
mid 30s 30 something i don't know she
was i'm pretty sure she's young she's
like 20 years she's kind of a babe are
you showing it to the people at home
she's kind of a babe okay go on so then
she goes all right bet i'll do it and
then she does it he gets elected she
becomes like the interim like press
secretary
and then like ends up leaving the
campaign but then comes back
and then last i think in january this
year and then gives his [ __ ]
but she's like just like some model no
experience and trump's like yo you're
gonna be you're gonna be my person
what does that say about trump like he's
able just to pick random people to do
these jobs
yeah like before he says anything about
trump i think it says something about
politics that's how easy this [ __ ] is
that's a better way to put it on this
whole time
it's hard to be a president no i used to
look at these people and be like yo
press secretary that's amazing like i
wonder like what ivy league you got to
go to and be honest i never thought
about that for press secretary
really any hybrid job
if you in the white house and you're
interacting with the president every day
i would have thought you are from like
an amazing pedigree
yeah your selfie word yeah yeah that's
to be the secretary
the president press secretary what do
you got to do
how does the president feel about it you
should talk to him
yo you're a vehicle that's literally
what you do you'll be a firefighter
well i look like the president i'm the
secretary
can i take a message i just called there
with some post-it notes
i'll put it on the oval office door here
you go zero hot copy of what he said
that's it
yo you would you do that job guys be a
press secretary yeah
yeah get the desk where you can get the
bobo underneath but no one can see
whoa you know the wooden desk with the
male secretary
taylor cover your ears with akash
cousin's hair
india say what where is it from where is
it from some other brown country i know
it's not from it's from sri lanka the
point is cheap ass hair right
point
is i don't i think that trump is
exposing something quite interesting
about government which is
any idiot can do it and i'm not saying
the girl is an idiot
but she's a model
so it's not like it's not like you can't
be smart as a model
but you cannot be you can definitely not
you cannot be smart
and be a model right right i think we've
all and i mean that for men
and women yeah like would you hire a
male model to do anything but model
l absolutely what if a guy was like i'm
a male model but now i can do audio
visual [ __ ]
nah mark is laughing at the idea
of him coming up here putting up the
lights with helena squeezing his abs to
get the v-line
zoolander is an entire movie about how
stupid male models are that's
it and imagine if you're a woman even
dumber
jokes taylor's on that period
she goes taylor came in saying she was
on her period so i got to be on good
behavior she said her pms was last week
but i got to be on good behavior
point is he is exposing you could just
put anybody in there right
the post office dude yeah the post
office general
yeah or whatever that is would you do
that postmates master master
son the postmaster how many masters we
got right they're trying to put
mastering a lot of [ __ ] yeah what if he
called himself the post
master is like i'll do it
i gotta change the name slightly taylor
don't look at me like that
i'm saying he was gonna do it not me
why are envelopes white why don't you
ask yourself these questions
okay the manila folder is yellow
where's manila uh philippines oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] maybe massa is running the [ __ ]
post office
how do white people greet each other
manila
you never heard that one no you never
heard white guys walk up to each other
and be like what's up my magga
i'm pretty sure that you have though
they do that and sometimes they use er
and i say dead that [ __ ] yeah
it's shout out they do haven't you heard
that [ __ ]
they got a lot of history behind it i
don't want to talk crazy i don't even
say it with the er
yeah make america greater okay
oh my god anyway point is
a lot of these jobs any of us could do
why have we been putting them on a
pedestal
because i just had a pedal school guys
pedestal pedal stool tell me i couldn't
be press secretary off right pedal stool
in the notes
it's pedestal why it's pedestal pad does
stell
now you're wildin bro yeah it's not
pedestal i thought it was a stool at
least
nah how do you spell it that's the most
trans black you've ever been
p-e-d-e-s-t-a-l
did you learn that a library
yeah i spent my valentine's days let me
ask you one thing
so so but for real i think a lot of
these positions you don't need any
expertise in ben carson right yes
this guy is a genius neurosurgeon okay
you know ben carson in trump's cabinet
the guy's the head of housing
what's that guy doing former head of
housing he's not still the head of
housing r.i.p
thought that's herman cain jesus
yeah jesus oh [ __ ]
see some would say they all look alike
ow you're a wild-ass boy over there bro
so there's not many black people in his
cabinet i'm surprised god
dude thank god you didn't say he was the
rice dude bro if you think that that
would be the most inappropriate comment
ever
uncle ben you know what i mean you got
that point is though you could do any of
these jobs
all of us could do these jobs what's so
difficult about it i don't think
i feel like y'all are getting confused
just because donald trump is in
office i feel like that's the point
donald trump is in office yeah
like i don't think that's how crazy you
have to prove that any of us could do it
honestly how hard is it to do that's
actually if we don't have a deep state
i'm a little concerned that's a great
point we need to
[ __ ] that the dummies end up doing when
they get in there yeah
if you got you got trump you need a deep
state you need a deep not even trump
all of them you need a deep i need a
deep state of young minds we're going up
against china
you think i need nancy pelosi going up
nancy pelosi chuck schumer china
you